basta che usciamo io sono contento
grazie gentile da porca bella tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sull'ia è un
gioco horror per la mia gioia cha va a
partire molto bravo spero e prego che
sia meglio di quello di prima che cazzo
è ma come salve ma non ti ho offeso
epoche potevi anche stare tra l'altro
era l'unica roba perché c'è un
orsacchiotto su chi tra l'altro è seduto
madonna è bruttissimo a casa un'amica
horror e per carità di dio ci starei
volentieri simo in staccata scuola stato
trovato una chiave vaso inutile bello
sicuramente più veloce il tizio che è
caduto per terra va bene non ho ben
capito a si apre sta roba
stai calmo non cadere non ti sto facendo
niente
quanto sei bello solo fare radio maria
rita affanculo
non me ne intendo ma non credo sia
nutella nella questa meno della
sicuramente non aprire per favore che
cazzo ci hai messo dentro un cadavere
non apro mai tranquilla zia non aprono
neanche volendo guardare
io entro però tu stai fermo fermo posso
prenderla questo grandissimo sai cosa
vuol dire la parola fermo devi stare
fermo in mo ma fermo proprio che strano
se un albero cade in una foresta e
nessuno intorno per poterlo sentire lui
genera un suono
io avrei un'altra domanda se per caso
esco dalla stanza e nessuno controlla
l'orsacchiotto lui si muove cioè questa
domanda che in questo momento è molto
più utile però andiamo su dall'altro la
stanza illuminata da dio perché animali
va una luce dal tetto qua ma come chiusa
ma camera mia come fa essere che ha
mentito strands aquino odio le cassette
di the ring
no no no no lo zio perché sta succedendo
questa cosa ha detto the ring ma stavo
scherzando e tu non mi guarda teniamo la
scienza che fa un po più bassa che non
mi a scavalco guarda sono più contento
se mi esce samara dalla televisione che
il tizio dal quadro che bello allegro
questo bagno
devo pagare ma non hai fatto niente
perché va beh non ho capito cosa devo
fare ragazzi si prova è come se fosse
aperta quella porta che ho detto che
devi stare fermo non devi mora la lazio
è capiamoci cos'è sta roba
la teenager muore dopo aver saltato da
un ponte vabbè cazzi suoi
lo sapevo cosa mi interessa di una
bambina che morta che si è lanciata da
un ponte che si lanci dove cazzo vuol a
leggere non è colpa mia se una bambina
si lancia da un ponte non la vede
nessuno fa qualche suono come chiamò
perché mi state prendendo per il culo a
cosa
[Applauso]
sì va beh no no no no no no no no no no
no non torna indietro a mazzo ti ammazzo
torna indietro no vabbè lega non ci
voglio stare io cos'è quella roba lì che
brutto salve che morisse il cugino di
terzo grado incastrato negli alberi devi
stare fece qualcosa scritto sopra ma non
del bridge with a quello che ha
costruito il ponte poi s'è buttata la
bambina bene mi fa molto piacere
avevo detto di stare fermo a te
deficiente ma dai veramente allora vedi
che non mi cagli il trasparente
alcuni hanno il coraggio di vivere altri
hanno il coraggio di morire e io che ho
il coraggio di levarmi dei [ __ ]
posso farlo ecco che c'era una porta un
nuovo banco vista si va beh ragazzi ma
datevi una regolata però datevi
veramente una regolata come si deve poi
tra l'altro mica potevamo fare un po più
alto suo soffitto ha messo a giocare a
sta roba
cos'è
la samp è gesù e tipo matrix che figata
cos'è sta roba
ancora tu ma dai sei gesù che gesù nel
nuovo millennio
non lo so va bene posso sapere da dove
arriva sua canzone
[Musica]
bene
vai e spero
mi ringrazi dopo il no per cortesia
salve posso entrare senza che mi stupri
la va bene possiamo uscire da questa
roba prima che qualcuno mi uccida grazie
no non ho neanche visto che cosa ha
fatto non lo voglio vi supplico iddio ci
aperta va bene
perfetto sono contento che tutto buio
fantastico beh ragazzi l'importante è
uscire come alla maturità basta che
usciamo nesso contento grazie gentile
para porca cos'era deficiente del da
minchia cos'era per cortesia mi fate
uscire ma cos'è ma doveva poi cadi
quella miglio e arte contemporanea va
bene non mi riguarda sono contento così
c'è una porta qualcosa grazie dio una
struttura particolare per una casa sono
proprio contento di essere entrato qua
dentro
ma siete scemi mi devo fare tutte le
scale preferisco farmi tutte le scale
andar giù che guarda piuttosto mi butto
giù importante carica
[Musica]
calmo vai vai vai vai veloce corrie non
puoi buttarti intanto non muori se ti
butti da credo e poi non lo so
vabbè tanto se non sono mica io 2 lotto
prego fate che questa sia l'ultima porta
non ce la posso più fare cos'è c'è un
biglietto ma non mi interessa se
riusciamo guarda bellissimo e la mostra
di quadri più bella che io abbia mai
visto negli ultimi anni dopo una visione
idilliaca basta che mi fate uscire da
questo piccolo vale di più
non lo so basta che usciamo ecco così
siamo allineati perfetti salve posso
leggere senza che nessuno mi stupri lano
fantastico lia e oliver che belli si
vede proprio che lei una bambina felice
anche lui va bene devo girarmi adesso
vero devo girarmi va bene non c'è niente
sul serio contrariato doveva esserci
qualcosa che mi saltava alla gola prove
ecco perché mi sembrava strade vo
buttarmi mi butto a ma non è un'amica
non vedo un cazzo
adesso possono strapiombo vado avanti un
secondo che mi vesto è un attimo
ora possiamo giocare insieme per sempre
agito gran gazzo effettivamente no che
succede
tutti i videogiochi horror alla fine
quando entra in una stanza che non si
apre più tutti questi cazzo di giochi
alla fine anno un jobs che grazie di non
averlo messo grazie sono una persona
felice pensavo che mi saltasse nel
monitor satana è belzebù tutti insieme
invece non è successo un cazzo
io amo supportiamo questi giochi dai
ragazzi questo era lì ha definito bene
per strano ebbene un cazzo però per me è
bene quindi ragazzi spero che video vi
sia piaciuto classense via piaciuto solo
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e cavani video trascrizioni
ser.t visti amici chiamano possibilità
ai ragazzi